como se verifica la situación que están
viviendo tanto los residentes de la
habana en libertad como las personas que
se encuentran en las cárceles desde las
protestas
hola buenas noches bueno la realidad es
que la situación que se está viviendo
tanto para las personas que están en
libertad como para los que están
privados de ella en los establecimientos
penitenciarios bastante críticas en las
calles hay escasez de todo tipo y sobre
todo hay unos niveles de represión muy
altos que les impide a la persona las
personas poder disfrutar del derecho a
tener una vida justa una vida correcta y
en las cárceles la situación es aún más
complicada porque a todas estas escasez
es se suma también los niveles de
represión y de estructura que ejerce el
gobierno cubano contra las personas que
están privadas y sobre todo por las
personas que están privados por motivos
políticos justamente cómo se lleva a
cabo esta represión sistemática del
estado según el análisis que ustedes han
hecho para evitar que se vuelvan a
presentar movimientos como el de hace un
año
si haber planteado al inicio algo que a
mí me parecía muy correcto muy ajustado
a la realidad y es que en los días
cercanos a que se conmemorará el primer
aniversario de estas protestas que
realmente han existido algo muy novedoso
para nuestra sociedad se ha estado
implantando todo un sistema de terror y
de hostigamiento a todas aquellas
personas que bien sean o periodistas
independientes o activistas o que por
algún motivo el gobierno cubano sospeche
que pueden lanzarse a las calles o que
pueden realizar algún tipo de
actividades en este caso yo creo que lo
que ha primado sobre todo es las
retenciones en los domicilios de las
personas retenciones que son a todas
luces ilegales porque no están
sustentadas por ninguna de nuestras
normas ni penales ni administrativas
entonces en ese sentido ese ha sido el
mecanismo que han utilizado y que le
queda por hacer a la comunidad
internacional además de las sanciones
contra los líderes del gobierno pues que
no tengan como objetivo a la sociedad
civil
yo creo que la comunidad internacional
tiene que comenzar a ser mucho más
enérgica en su condena hacia el régimen
cubano y apoyar mucho más a la sociedad
civil cubana trata de empoderar la mucho
más desde nuestra organización y en
conjunto con otras organizaciones de
derechos humanos llevamos algún tiempo a
raíz de este aniversario del 11 ago
estás tratando de instar a todas las por
todos los órganos de tratados de
derechos humanos para que se pronuncien
de manera efectiva contra cuba que
implementen no sólo sanciones sino
también que insten al gobierno humano a
que cumpla con su obligación de respetar
los derechos